ready to kick off the new year with a
new console if you haven't made the leap
to Xbox one yet Microsoft has two new
January bundles to win you over the
first bundle is all about Tom Clancy 400
bucks gets you a one terabyte console
and Rainbow six siege you'll also get
digital copies of rainbow six vegas one
and two which work through xbox one's
backward compatibility the bundle is
shipping to retailers today and is
available in most territories if you're
not a Tom Clancy fan then the name your
game bundle is for you for 350 bucks
you'll get a 500 gigabyte console and
your choice of ports of Motorsports six
gears the bar eltham it edition rare
replay or rise of the Tomb Raider that
bundle is shipping to a few territories
on January 12 then to some others
including the US later in the month
there's no shortage of xbox one bundles
to browse if neither of these caught
right there are plenty more on the Xbox
website and whenever microsoft announces
the next batch you can bet your Kinect
you'll hear about it from GameSpot this
is Tony signing out
you